our chief negotiate mr. limbani informed
us on state of play
we had exchange of views on the latest
developments there has been some
progress in the negotiations but clear
divergences remain in all of the key
issues citizens rights financial
settlement now Eris border there is lot
of work to do and time is of the essence
we of course listen to Prime Minister
mace last week speech and we we welcome
the constructive approach we expect this
to be reflected in positions of the UK
government at the negotiating table
progress will be assessed only based on
the negotiations when we share the goal
of establishing close partnership
between the you and UK after withdrawal
we need sufficient progress on key
issues of first phase and to provide
clarity and protection to our citizens
and businesses the eu-27 remain united
we have single line of negotiations
clearly defined mandate and we fully
support the work of of Michel Barnier
cacodemon no se que la Granja de una
camisa de Clara's audit a resume
Dada position presses de negocio some
don't
da da Mahmoud crafty a particle a solid
wad a situation hydromorphone o co in
Tsavo does well see the relation
solution unique concern oh yeah not new
dois the residences at parrot release no
solitaire do to cause issued the virus
periodic see no see applicable market
area alpha C progressed very quickly
last precocial necessary proclaim the
condition of the coastal news of all
boos one